yesterday Rob stone said that he
criticized the US Women's National Team
for the 30 no win saying that they
should have pulled back a little bit
knocked it around a little bit and Rob
got roughed up on social media
the unamerican Rob stone joining us hey
Rob hey Rob and just like that he's gone
USA cut his own line yeah he hung up on
you apparently the ugly American called
me on an anti-american hey back if you
missed any of the interviews including
Rob stone you can go to the dealer one
of his better appearance yes Dan Patrick
show app where you can watch and listen
from inside the mercedes-amg mancave
mercedes-amg driving performance Fritzi
working feverishly to get Rob stone back
Fritzi is Rob there with us he's back
alright Rob how are you hey once you
told me social media went after me I
just hung up the phone I'm not a tree
games going on today you mean social
medias angry they're certainly about
something what if I known as the bride
okay
it's an amazing way to fight the issue
yes yes
did you realize at the time because
there's two issues at play here Rob its
scoring and celebrating I have no
problem with scoring I had a problem
when the late goals in the amount of
celebrating I just think you know what
it's Thailand save your energy you're
gonna need it yeah man there's even more
levels to that in in my book but that
was my I think the big thing his optics
right then we're sitting here as fans
with the team that were were really
proud of and has carried this mantle for
for soccer and the women's game for four
decades across the globe and then to see
them really just kind of put take take
Thailand out to the woodshed and the
damage had been done this game was over
this team was beaten messages had been
sent I just didn't see me personally
this is just me being being a kindness
and generous human being this is over
this is done we don't were not getting
we're not learning anything more from
this and
and and also this wasn't a level playing
field yeah you can say yes every 24 all
24 nations deserve to be here at the
World Cup and in some fashion they did
but if you're telling the US and
Thailand we're on equal footing
economically in the set up in the talent
of these players it's a joke and it
wasn't level footing you know this
wasn't this wasn't Brazil Germany at the
Men's World Cup several years ago where
were Germany put us something on Brazil
those two nations were on equal footing
this wasn't this was a mismatch to start
with look their job is to win right
their job is to win the day their job is
to win the women's woke up I have 100%
respect in what they did but as I sat
there watching it as a soccer fan as a
soccer connoisseur as a parent as a fan
as a human being I said enough is enough
you know I was looking for a towel to
throw in and I said I don't think we
need to see this anymore and then for
them to continue to score that was a
tough tale but to see the celebrations
hurt it hurt me because to me it lead of
an ugly American a week of American
arrogance and that is something I've
I've tried for so long of my life to
avoid having said that you do have to
take a step back down and realize that
these women have sacrificed their lives
for sacrifice years have blood sweat
tears time away from loved ones done
everything they can to get to this stage
and then when you get to this stage and
you score a goal
boy that is awfully hard to mute a
celebration I think in the end a lot of
people would have been happier if had
you scored there was a hug there was a
high-five and you turned around and he
went back up and he said let's kick it
off let's play again yeah well now you
got Chile coming up and if the world
rankings that I've been following
closely are true then Chile is worse
than Thailand right right so we could be
dealing with this again Sunday here in
Paris on Father's Day and you know the
u.s. women the reaction is trickling in
into their camp we had Megan Rapinoe on
our air earlier the day and she said you
know if there's anything we need to be
blamed for it's an overabundance of
energy
enjoy and
again I do understand the happiness and
yes you should celebrate a goal but
again at that point in that stage piling
on because it was a flurry of goals in
the last handful of minutes that you
just kind of said at some point again as
a be enough is enough as a competitor a
hundred percent understand where they
are coming from that you play until the
final whistle you play to win the game
is our friend Herm Edwards likes to say
and with that viewpoint you're looking
at these athletes who are at the
absolute top tier of what they do and
you say I am trained I am trained to
keep going I'm trained to keep hunting
you're going to tell that dog to stop
hunting good luck with that also we're
talking to Rob stone the Fox Sports
Women's World Cup host joining us from
Paris you know the whole equal pay here
if if I took a poll in the United States
of would you rather watch the women play
or the men play who wins boof I think if
you're talking US national teams I my
guess is you might get a few more votes
for the women's team than the men I
don't know I think overall people would
prefer to see the Men's World Cup over
the Women's World Cup but with women's
software as a whole is a 1% growth
industry and it's really right by the US
it's led by what France is doing here
this summer as well and and part of the
drive of this World Cup and what we've
seen up until that game Dan was that
nations have closed the gap Argentina
you know in their first World Cup in two
decades was able to earn a point with
Japan who are runners-up four years ago
a huge moment for that country and
really for that region of the world
we've seen other smaller countries make
a big dent early on here at the Women's
World Cup and there was the conversation
that everybody's kind of catching up to
the u.s. is to the Germany's to the
French and that's a good thing but then
you see again the optic of that 13-0
lambasting and you say look the US
Women's National Team has been the
leader on this front for it really as
far as we know as soccer
and to see what they did kind of humble
a country it didn't sit well when we're
trying to grow this game and some people
will counter Dan that say you know what
these are the type of results that
women's soccer needs because it sends
messages to those countries to those
Federation's to FIFA do the people
supplying the funds through these
programs that say more needs to be
invested or time more money or coaching
experience more education more player
development and that's an argument that
you can make and I can buy but in the
end I just kind of bend my knees in and
I inhale and exhale and I say if you
just got out of there at 9 0 10 0 I
don't think anybody would be making
storm about this right keeps turning up
over there Rob we appreciate it and
we'll be watching later today thanks
buddy you got my number call me anytime
that's Rob stone Fox Women's World Cup
host he's hosting the pre-match coverage
at 11:00 a.m. Eastern on Fox ahead of
Germany versus Spain at noon eastern
France vs. Norway that's at 3:00 Eastern
and Rob is part of Fox Sports FIFA
Women's World Cup coverage all month
long on Fox and Fox Sports 1 for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]